[Music]  how do you feel that being a father has  changed you as a man and an actor I  think you're just more desperate in  everything you do because you're like I  got 10 minutes to do this and then I got  to get home for a thing and a thing and  a thing yeah there's just no time  anymore so you're hardened by you know  anxiety I think that's probably it  we're in Austin what's the what's what  do you want to do here what's the fun  thing to do what are your plans eat  there's really good food and often so  eat my family's here and they went  swimming today that was fun yeah yeah  yeah  swimming I want to pee just go swimming  yeah but I had to hang out with him all  day she can send you Blake this is the  dynamic duo of Austin yeah yeah I know  well it does more importantly both names  riders  oh it's Blake feeling about this being  replaced so soon Ryan okay I know right  it's not even replace it's just I feel  like anybody talked to me about how I  feel about  [Music]  you